-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#myweirdroommate stories
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one
is from @chrislilli.
He says, "I used to live
with a guy"...
[ Audience groans ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
This one is from @MelLynn.
She says, "My roommate"...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay.
Just terrified.
This one is from @wyyyyyit.
-How many Y's?
-I think it's five Y's.
-W-h --
-W-y-y-y-y-y-i-t.
Wyyyyit.
-Wyyyyit.
-She says,
"I wanted to get out"...
[ Audience oohs ]
-Do you like piña coladas?
-[ Chuckles ]
-This next one's from @mahuls.
-Oh. Mahuls.
-She said --
You know mahuls?
-Oh, mahuls.
I love mahuls.
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's not
the non-alcoholic beverage
that you drink.
-Oh, it's not?
-That is O'Doul's.
-Oh, that's O'Doul's.
Okay. I'm sorry.
I love O'Doul's.
-Mahuls is a non-alcoholic bar.
-Non-alcoholic. [ Laughs ]
-The whole bar, non-alcoholic.
That's actually a play land.
It's a Gymboree.
-It's a Gymboree.
-Gymboree for children.
Yeah, it's not even for adults.
It's for children.
-The ball pit.
-It's a trampoline park.
-Yeah.
-I don't want to get into it.
-Lot of lawsuits.
-[ Chuckles ]
Lot of lawsuits.
Because there's no license.
-No, zero licensing.
And it's filthy.
-Actually, it is a bar.
It's a trampoline bar.
Anyways.
-Wait, it's a trampoline bar?
-Anyways.
Yes, and there's a 6-foot pool
in there, as well.
You could trampoline
into the pool and drink.
It's awful.
They should close it down.
I've been saying,
"Please close mahuls."
[ Laughter ]
I've always said that.
-Oh, you've always said that.
You have that tattoo.
-This is -- I do.
I never get to see it.
-No, you can't see it.
-That's the only --
That's the problem.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-That's why I can't sleep
at night.
I can't see most of my tattoos.
-You should get a mirror
that's a double mirror
so you can see yourself
in the mirror backwards
so you can read your tattoos.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, I think.
But I'm a vampire,
so I can't even --
I don't have a reflection.
-Oh, I forgot.
I forgot.
-I don't have a reflection.
You don't understand what --
-You're Count Dracula Jr.
-[ As Sara ] You don't even
understand what my life is like.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You don't understand
what my life is like!
Vampire with tattoos.
[ Normal voice ] All right.
This is from @mahuls.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
She says,
"My roommate would"...
Oh, God!
-Oh!
That's that.
Uh, I'm missing, uh,
singles 7 through 10.
[ Laughter ]
-Did anybody eat those?
-Anyone hungry?
That's what I thought.
[ Laughter ]
Someone's eating my cheese.
-We're going to mahuls.
-We are going to mahuls.
Meet me there if you want to.
Well, that's my last name.
-Yeah.
-Oh, can you get us in?
No cover charge?
-For three Kraft singles.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckles ] Because
we're three crafty singles.
And a little cheesy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
All right.
Let's just go.
[ Mumbles ]
-Come on!
♪♪
Oh, his tattoo is acting up.
Walking across the stage.
Waving goodbye.
♪♪
Oh, my gosh!
You're taping
this whole episode.
-No, this is --
[ Laughter ]
Alexa, reco--
Alexa, record the To--
[ Thud ]
Uh, it wasn't Alexa.
It's felt tape.
Hey, this next one.
-Who is it from?
-This is from @paisleee.
-Oh, I love her.
[ Laughter ]
-She says, "There was a fire"...
[ Laughter and applause ]
All right.
Are you November?
[ Chuckles ]
[ Light laughter ]
Fireman calendar.
Okay.
-Thank you.
Fireman calendar reference,
right?
Classic bit.
-November.
-Jimmy names
the fireman calendars.
[ Laughs ]
-You see, on calendars --
-Mr. November.
That's what I meant to say.
This one's from @brianricci.
He says,
"Every time my roommate"...
[ Laughs ]
No?
"I get it.
Do you get it?"
"No."
"I don't get it either."
-"Do you think it's funny?"
-This last one
is from @mmmargolies.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-M.M.
-M.M. Margolies.
-M&M.
[ Light laughter ]
-[ As Mahna Mahna ]
Mah-nay mah-nem.
-♪ M.M. Margolies ♪
-Mah-nay mah-nem.
-♪ Margolies, too ♪
-♪ Margoo, Margolies ♪
♪ Margolies, Margolies ♪
♪ We're going to drink
at mahuls ♪
-[ Scatting ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] This last one's
from @mmmargolies.
He says, "Once,
I couldn't figure out"...
There you go.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" Hashtags.
Check out more of our favorites.
Go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.